[Música]
tengo 19 estoy estudiando en sadelback
un colegio comunitario cercano me estoy
especializando en desarrollo
inmobiliario y hago fotografía y actúo
la verdad no son malas las gafas son
divertidas Yo también me tomé una foto
así me gusta
la etapa incómoda de la vida realmente
no son malas mi hermana pequeña también
es animadora así que pensé en ella hubo
un momento en que se veía así O sea hay
alguna foto del anuario que sea buena
todo es malo cuando tomas una foto del
anuario o sea es realmente una etapa
incómoda de la vida todas fueron tomadas
en la escuela al menos las primeras
cuatro y la escuela es la escuela así
que no las culpo esta también es
divertida solo es un mal ángulo y la
cara borrosa en la parte de atrás
también es divertida tuve acné así que
me identifico con esta he tomado muchas
fotos como esa
mostrándome acné y tratando de mejorarlo
esta también es graciosa Esta es la del
principio son mis favoritas porque está
tiene un doble mentón y Súper bajo es
incómodo y divertido
tengo que dar una razón para eliminarlas
me gustaría escuchar una razón
Qué malvada me siento realmente mal voy
a ir con la concursante
3 realmente no sé la razón solo pienso
que la número 3 se va primero
Hola Hola un placer Lo siento mucho me
siento mal es un placer
eres hermosa también me gusta tu atuendo
es genial
Me siento tan mal no te sientas mal lo
entiendo las pelirrojas somos un gusto
adquirido entonces pensé que sería la
primera en irme o la última quién será
la próxima eliminada
número 7
Hola encantado y la otra chica de mi
edad y vamos a ser eliminadas Ahora sí
No la verdad no son tan malas Bueno sí
lo son
lo tuyo es divertida cuántos años tenías
creo que como 14 no está mal Solo eras
joven Okay encantada de conocerte
también gracias
muy bien concursante 1 puedes hablarme
de las gafas sí
es una imagen muy tonta un día estábamos
en clase de química tenía como 14 o 15
años y mi mejor amiga con quien todavía
soy muy cercana simplemente dijo posa
justo ahí sonríe de la forma en la que
siempre lo haces Y a ellos se le ocurrió
un alter ego para mí y de ahí vino Jerry
no estaba a punto de preguntar quién es
Jerry todavía me parece que es una cosa
muy linda ella Todavía me llama Jerry es
el apodo que me tiene de ahí vino la
historia me encanta esa fotografía
realmente tiene personalidad cuántos
años tenías o unos 14 o 15 bien número
dos puedes hablarme de tu foto sí estaba
en una etapa incómoda de la vida pero
era animadora así que solo sonreí mi
mamá me dijo sonríe y le dije Oh por
Dios Así es como me veo pero está bien
Sí las mamás nunca toman buenas fotos
así que tranquila número 4 hablarme de
tu foto sí tenía 15 o 16 y esa fue la
graduación de secundaria de mi mejor
amiga Me veía bien para mí en ese
momento mirando hacia atrás no es mi
mejor momento pero podría haber sido
peor número cinco
estaba en una producción de musical
preparándome para el espectáculo y uno
de mis compañeros pensó que sería
divertido tomar fotos a mitad de mi
maquillaje con mi teléfono mientras
estaba en ese ángulo entonces obtienes
esa gloriosa frente número 6 bueno tenía
alrededor de 15 a 16 años mi acnera
realmente malo y esa era la mayor
inseguridad que tenía en ese momento y
yo estaba como sabes qué déjame tomar
una foto sabes Tal vez hasta salga linda
no sabía si iba a pasar eso o no Yo hice
lo mismo
Creo que será la número
2 Hola Hola un placer un placer
Cómo estás bien otra chica hermosa Sí
gracias Un placer Igualmente La número
dos es muy bonita
número 5
Hola Hola
un placer Igualmente Me gusta tu ropa se
ve increíble gracias Te gustó mi foto
creo que es la más divertida que hay
primera y segunda creo sí no sé cómo
consiguieron esa Pero buen trabajo
Se parece a Elvis no sé si es porque
tengo el tráiler de las nuevas películas
de Elvis en mi cabeza pero con el
cabello Así se ve como un mono grasiento
pero en el buen sentido
Esta es para todas cuántos años tienen
están en la universidad A qué se dedican
y en qué trabajan tengo 21 Actualmente
estoy en el último año de la outla a
punto de graduarme en dos meses e
intento trabajar en algo a lo largo de
las líneas de marketing muy bien Me
rechazaron de la ucla ayer Así que lo
siento mucho
culpa es bueno hola tengo 20 no estoy en
la universidad iba a ir después de
graduarme Pero simplemente no me gustaba
por el tema en línea así que me mudé
aquí Y viví el automóvil durante unos
cinco o seis meses ahora trabajo en las
redes sociales es genial de dónde eres
soy de Albuquerque Nuevo México genial
Hola qué tal también tengo 20
Actualmente estoy haciendo una doble
especialización en bienes raíces y
enfermería ambas en escuelas diferentes
bienes raíces en un colegio comunitario
local Así que espero tener mi licencia
este año y graduarme de enfermería en
los próximos dos años bien Qué hay de ti
tengo 19 me estoy mudando ahora mismo me
acaban de rechazar de la upla Y todavía
estoy esperando por otras universidades
cuáles son sus pasatiempos la música es
una de mis mayores aficiones me encanta
cantar y formo parte del grupo de
actuación de la ucla amo hacerlo tu
canción favorita para cantar o para
escuchar para cantar probablemente
de Nina Simón para escuchar
probablemente
el que nunca podría cansarme
quieres regalarnos un poco de canto Sí
por supuesto haré la canción que comenté
no me río
lo mío también es la música llevo
escribiendo canciones unos 11 años y
cantando casi toda mi vida sí solo para
pasar el rato también es un pasatiempo
genial
Supongo que mi pasatiempo en este
momento no quiero sonar como una rata de
gimnasio pero pasó mucho tiempo en el
gimnasio intento ir todos los días
también hago crochet siento que eso es
algo
que te gusta escuchar
No es muy común Pero me gusta mucho la
música country
cualquier cosa en la radio pero el
country es mi favorito nací en El Paso
Texas Así que crecí por esos Lares pero
no a todo el mundo le gusta sí
comprensible estoy bromeando me encanta
la música country crecí en la misma zona
desafortunadamente voy a eliminar a
Jerry
Hola hola encantado de conocerte
Es un placer de dónde vino Jerry
de la mente de mi amiga algo que la
inspirara ella es un genio Jerry se ha
quedado conmigo y ella es como mi alter
ego y me gusta mantener el lado tonto y
divertido la vida pasa rápido me
entiendes Entonces ella es como la niña
dentro de mí en todo lo que hago buena
foto me gusta Gracias te agradezco de
nada Honestamente el canto desafinado
fue más vergonzoso en mi mente que la
foto lo hiciste bien gracias
próxima eliminación
número 6
Hola hola
encantada soy Anaya Marcel bienes raíces
es genial
yo es tan difícil yo estaba en bienes
raíces mismos Qué tan lejos estás de tu
licencia Solo dos meses muy bien así que
en dos meses voy a hacer mi Prueba con
suerte paso a la primera pasada
Igualmente es como esperaba que se viera
justo cuando dijo que le interesaban los
bienes raíces tenía una imagen de cómo
era definitivamente alguien que me
hubiera enamorado en el pasado
estás emocionado sí okay sientes que
tomaste la decisión correcta y creo que
sí podrías número 4 por favor salir
ahora
Hola un placer encantada
un placer conocerte Bueno Pensé que
tenías una historia genial gracias Qué
amable Sí qué haces para las redes
actualmente vivo en una casa de
contenido y hago trabajo de asistente
Eso es todo por ahora estoy tratando de
entrar en la gestión sí
bien bien genial muy genial
tan satisfechos puedes colocarte al lado
de tu foto sí estaba en su mejor versión
me fastidiaron mucho en la secundaria y
preparatoria por mi apariencia y una
mañana no sé solo comencé a ponerme
progresivamente más linda
progresivamente no es tan malo
Cuando ahora Oh no
pareces un pequeño niño de teatro está
horrible está bien Sí estaba en un viaje
familiar mi página de fotografías
comenzó a tener seguidores Y pensé que
era como un influencer pensé que me veía
bien
y luego me di cuenta de que
definitivamente No
eso era una trampa para la sed en ese
momento pensé que lo era pero Qué
significa para ti la mejor versión
obviamente asumir que tu físico brilla
pero también creo que tiene que ver con
la confianza y llegar a ser uno mismo y
finalmente descubrir cómo trabajar con
lo que tienes como persona creo que una
vez que descubres Cómo hacer eso esa es
tu mejor versión todo se toman su propio
tiempo y espacio para crecer en su
propio cuerpo si veo una foto mala hoy
en día no es me veo mal soy fea es esta
es una foto mala y yo soy una persona
hermosa me voy a tatuar eso en la cara
siento que es como esa foto en la que
acabas de llegar a casa con un nuevo
corte de pelo y es como mirarte en el
espejo y decir sí me veo bien no está
tan mal no está mal para nada Solo diré
que volvería a tomarme una foto como esa
es bueno que tengas esa confianza